where's the committee on far left
extremism antifa we talk about January 6
and the the unjust actions that were
taken for a lot of these people some of
these people I think were violent should
be criminally charged you know like I
said Tucker shows the violent footage
but just uh this in this past week in
the past few months we've had we had a
group of 150 far left extremists break
into a government compound a facility in
Georgia fire bomb buildings and
equipment
some of these people were not from this
country one of them was a lawyer for the
Southern Poverty Law Center
the Southern Poverty Law Center admitted
it and said that you know he's a legal
Observer and then the spokesperson
tweets out a a hashtag in support of the
terrorists these people have been
charged with domestic terrorism
how is it that the entire cycle
the news cycle I understand the media is
going to ignore it but where are we in
terms of putting together the select
committee on far left extremism how
about we have the May 29th Insurrection
panel the select committee on the May 29
on 529 and we can talk about the
far-lift Extreme as to tour down the
barricades of the White House fire
bombed a guard posts that fire to St
John's Church injuring I think around 70
70 to 100 police officers forcing the
president into a bunker how about we get
we bring cops in to testify on that cops
who are injured we bring in Witnesses
and journalists and we put all of that
on the record
so I'm here for it okay understand
though
remember that in a lot of ways the two
parties do the same thing in Washington
and so the only reason we have a select
committee on the weaponization of
government is because when Matt and I
said we're going to negotiate over who
gets to be the speaker we're not just
going to cast votes just because
180 of the members Republican members
say we're going to do it that was great
by the way well I mean you know the
first couple days it wasn't so great
yeah but uh I mean for us but I thought
it was important to do so Matt we stuck
to our guns that's really the first time
people have
there have been a lot of coup efforts I
guess you'd call them if you want to
call it that I wouldn't it's a bad word
that's a bad word that's what they call
it that's a friend of ours in Congress
called it from multiple coup efforts
against the you know they call us the
Taliban 20 yeah yeah yeah that is the
coolest nickname I have ever been apart
Crenshaw said we were in legislative
terrorists but but that was it was we
stuck to our guns and uh and and part in
a a very material part of the agreement
that we in fact I negotiated The
Authority for that subcommittee myself
and um and and uh so these aren't easy
to get in the sense that a lot of people
want to
ignore stuff and yeah the question will
be to what extent were U.S taxpayer
dollars used to try to fuel some of
those groups through ngos through a lot
of this diversity equity and inclusion
funding that we do I think we got our
next guest here man all right Steve oh
yeah yeah we'll uh we'll rotate down and
uh let the honey badger join us so I
think the mics I I see people saying
pull the mic back I push the mic way
back because it looks like they're very
sensitive on top of them or something I
guess the they're picking up very
they're picking up too well now okay of
course right right it was like really
quiet we're like trying to get closer
then we're like pull away pull away
gotcha but uh is that is that Joel Steve
coming in yeah five you got to get
accustomed to that so what to the to the
vibe oh the vibe yeah it isn't Vibe I
I'm I blame the Deep State for the audio
problems it happened last time no the
last last time we had the audio problem
what's up look at this Steve Bannon the
honey badger in the capital
it doesn't get any better never met the
man myself hey Dan Bishop how you doing
honor good to meet you so
we'll let Bannon get seated we're
talking about Dan and my trip to
go through all of the January 6th
committee documents uh Adam kinzinger
was able to get they sent their two
right guys well it's We Believe today
was the first time that any lawmakers
are you going to host and direct to
direct the whole thing yeah absolutely
uh so here's what we were talking about
and I'm curious in your thoughts uh Mr
Bannon
uh some kind of antifa committee or at
least a component of exploring the far
left extremism we're actively seeing
right now
we I think we get two things out of it
one accountability for what we saw in
Georgia what we saw in Portland what we
saw with Chaz and all that stuff
it's accountability uh we could stop
what's actively going on if we shine a
light on it we can get accountability
for the past actions and then I think it
might wake up a lot of Americans to the
degree of violent extremism coming from
the left that's not being portrayed in
Media
I think it's a great idea I think what
we need is to put all the effort into
reconstituting a j6 committee
and let them have a ranking member in a
minority Council and set it all up and
go back to the beginning I think I think
that's one of the biggest things in the
country and I think you need top people
like we have here on this committee and
it's all the information has got to come
out on the intelligence services on the
FBI everything what we knew what we
didn't know all of it I mean Tucker did
a thing don't get me wrong the F the
antifa's needed two but I only think
we've got
so much bandwidth to do things and this
is this is this has to be answered yeah
it can't continue on like it is you
can't continue to rely on guys like
Tucker doing a heroic job with the 44
000. we need a formal investigation
a select committee if you have to of
major players in the Democratic Party in
the Republican party not like the show
trial she had but actually have a
ranking member you've said that a few
times yeah and and it is a decision
point we are at right now because
Democrats have used their presence in
these transcribed interviews to obstruct
the investigation yes to try to deter
whistleblowers to smear patriotic
Americans who joined the premier law
enforcement agency in the world because
they love our country as we all should
and I don't think they should get to
participate anymore in those transcribed
interviews if they are using that
courtesy to try to do harm to the
investigation and you're saying bring
them in due to them better than they did
I just think look I I think in that
regard they play Smash Mouth I think we
have to start playing Smash Mouth right
but I think you have to cons if you
don't constitute it where they get the
information are able to cross-examine
Witnesses we're gonna have the exact
same show trial we had the first time
Steve these are these are such deep
issues
but the American people have to get to
the but we have to get to the bottom of
this this is like Watergate this is like
Iran Contra this is like the 911
Commission you know they always say it's
like Pro per Harbor had seven different
commissions four of them in the Capitol
right and they still never quite got to
think but they kept going over and over
because the American people deserve
answers we deserve the American people
deserve answers even if you guys and I
think there's enough tough guys like
yourself that can get in there and make
sure they're not leaking depositions
they're not playing games with the press
all of that it's gonna be tough but it's
I think it's gonna happen one thing I
found interesting when we went through
the files today they are incredibly well
organized and as it relates to outgoing
documents they are almost completely
complete uh you can go through by name
you can pull uh the I pulled the Charlie
Kirk file and I saw the way that the
Turning Point organization was targeted
and is actually still being unfairly
targeted I pulled the Bernie Carrick
file and saw the way they went after him
I I you know pulled the mark short file
and I saw how eager he was to cooperate
and how even with friendly Witnesses
they they played this game with the
subpoena nonetheless but there was one
file
with no documents in it that I reviewed
and it was the Steve Bannon file no
documents there was the same filed
they've taken it it's waiting for me in
federal prison for my four-month
sentence right the warden will have it I
I I in a I'm sure justice has it in a
circumstance where they were so
meticulous to have everything indexed
and included and in in almost every case
you saw a letter and like clockwork
within 14 days a subpoena that followed
that letter
and nothing on the Bannon Fox so it's
empty it is a file there is it there we
found the seed bathroom nothing there
man well I actually I I not to get my
trials and appeal but I I think if you
did it's not that what what I would want
to do j6 but there's no doubt that the
to me the uh The General Counsel for the
committee perjured herself multiple
times in my trial to have a general
account say oh I didn't know that was
happening I didn't know it's just it's
it's Beggar's belief it's incredible
well and also for this person uh we we
are we are looking at the members and
records and I want to know how far they
cross the line when we exercise our
subpoena power because what I observed
was that almost every week this the
committee was sending out to Sprint
Verizon T-Mobile to Google Voice
all of these phone numbers I want all of
their records yes all of these bank
accounts all these Amex cards all the
the PayPal accounts people had wanting
all of the records it was such a wide
Dragnet and I wonder whether or not some
of these phone numbers are going to
match up to members of Congress yes I
wonder if they're going to match our
staffs it was interesting to see that
the subpoenas depicted
there must have been some very good
conversation going on between big tech
companies big telecom companies and the
committee because the committee would
send out a subpoena to the to the banks
and it would say it would ask for these
internal file numbers of the bank and
they'd give like 30 file numbers
right but they nonetheless then
subpoenaed it uh and got it so but you
know that kind of relationship is but
that even of itself
even if you don't reconstitute the
committee which I strongly recommend you
guys do just to put that in front of the
American people
of how gun deck this thing was right how
organized it was with with these parts
but what Tim is saying is that we need
to pick up these tools and and use them
to deconstruct what is a dangerous
weaponized left 100 what uh well so for
one I I I'm fascinated by the fact that
we have active anti-fotera right you
know I hate to say antifa it's far left
it's it's a plethora of of of groups or
whatever actively firebombing houses
they flipped the guy's truck over random
guy flip this truck over sat on fire
they shot a cop this is escalating for a
French and a Canadian guy were involved
NGO lawyer was involved so we have that
actively happening but but I do agree I
think
for what I think the American people
aren't being told what's going on
because it's being ignored by the Press
because it's bad for them they want to
side with their audience and I think we
can force them to cover it if we had
some kind of hey look we're going to do
the same thing at the same time
I'd love it if you guys subpoenaed Ray
apps
I don't know that would have to be part
of it that I think you have to use the
facial recognition and go to the DHS and
go you have to find out how many federal
agents were there yes there was
obviously federal agents you have to
have I mean my point is you have to go
back to the beginning and find out what
people knew until I had Chris Miller the
acting Secretary of Defense at the time
you know he was on the show he had a
book came out it's 300 pages long 20
Pages deal with this situation I think
I'm the only guy who read it because
he's got explosives he he as secretary
of defense couldn't get anybody
organized in FBI or just anything to
even have a meeting to plan on security
he just keeps watching TV so he finally
called they would meet on Sunday
afternoon before the Tuesday
I think January 2nd or 3rd
he uh has a zoom call now this is the
acting Secretary of Defense he's got the
FBI doj all of it and uh they're sitting
there going yeah we have intelligence
it's going to be 35 000 people there
and he goes gosh they had a million in
in November 12th they had 75 000 on the
14th hey says oh we've done this we got
until 35 000. and he goes well you know
can we help can we get troops can we get
National Guard I can get all the stuff
in the any and that he was told no the
DC Metro and Capitol Hill Police can
handle up to a million protesters and
and it's fine and that won't be that'll
be fine and he says well how many Mario
Bowser that finally asked for 325
National Guard which he deployed to
Andrews Air Force Base we didn't learn
to find out didn't want him in the city
Andrews Air Force Base which is you know
45 miles minutes away traffic he goes to
the White House next day for Trump on
another separate meeting
and Trump's sitting there and you know
the game it's another man I think
they're going to pull the troops out of
Korea right so he's leaving and Trump
goes hey are you ready for tomorrow and
he goes well I think we are sir he says
what do you know what are you doing he
says well we've had this big meeting and
I've got 325 troops here go to Andrews
and Trump goes now you're going to need
10 000. you should call up ten thousand
it's in the book right there he says
Trump said you're going to need 10 000.
you should get him up
and he's such a pre-station and he says
well they don't want it the mayor
doesn't want it Nancy Pelosi doesn't
want it nobody wants it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time